tomaten sind eines der ruhigsten gemüse
im ganzen gemüsegarten und eine frage
habt ihr mir immer wieder gestellt in
den letzten wochen nämlich wie zum
teufel dünne ich meine tomaten so dass
sie mit allem versorgt sind was sie
brauchen
darum soll es heute gehen ich werde euch
erzählen welche nährstoffe tomaten
überhaupt brauchen und warum ihr erkennt
ob eure tomaten hunger haben also ob sie
eine portion dünger gebrauchen könnten
und wann er welchen dünger verwendet und
wie ihr erkennt ob ihr zu viel gedüngt
habt also bleibt bis zum ende mit dabei
ist auf jeden fall spannend viel spaß
mit dem heutigen video heute nämlich
noch nicht kennst ich bin marie ich
studiere ökologische landwirtschaft und
bau das obst und gemüse firma eine
familie fast komplett selber an und die
erfahrungen die wir dabei gesammelt
haben und weiter sammeln man lernt ja
nie aus
die gebe ich hier auf dem youtube kanal
an euch weiter und auch in meinen kursen
ich freue mich sehr weil ich eure
tomaten freundin sein darf dieses jahr
wir haben ganz viele tomaten videos
geplant
und wenn ihr euch dafür interessiert
also wenn ihr wollt dass ich euch das
ganze jahr über mit den tipps versorgen
die ihr braucht damit eure tomaten zu
neuen höchstleistungen auflaufen dann
abonniert gerne den kanal
es kommen wie gesagt regelmässig bis in
den spätsommer hinein immer wieder
tomaten videos hier auf dem kanal ja
jedes gemüse hat ja so ein bisschen in
unterschiedlichen geschmack dass die
nährstoffe angeht tomaten stehen vor
allem auf fünf sachen die wollen sie
gerne in der erde haben mit denen wollen
sie gerne versorgt sein
der wichtigste pflanzennährstoff für
alle stark sehr abzulehnen tomaten
erzählen ist natürlich stickstoff
stickstoff ist für das massen wachstum
zuständig dafür dass die schön in die
höhe wachsen können für das blatt
wachstum das ist also eine komponente
die tomaten in kusel menge brauchen dann
brauchen tomaten auch phosphor das ist
vor allem wichtig damit sie schön viele
wurzeln bilden können und auch blüten
bilden können aus denen ja später die
früchte entstehen und das kalium was sie
brauchen ihr habt euch wahrscheinlich
schon gedacht denn pks und sehr wichtige
nährstoffe für rohe tomaten das kalium
ist dann dafür da dass die früchte sich
richtig schön bilden können dass die
auch aus reifen
das sind also drei wichtige stoffe auf
die ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon selber
gekommen seid dann gibt es aber auch
noch zwei staffeln die nicht so
offensichtlich sind das einmal schwefel
und das ist einer magnesium
da habe ich euch ja schon in meinem
video wo wir tomaten gepflanzt haben
oder in meinen letzten beiden
tomatenpflanze videos gezeigt dass sich
da immer magnesium sulfat mit ins
pflanzloch gebe so dass die tomaten mit
magnesium und schwefel magnesium sulfat
enthält magnesium und schwefel gut
versorgt sind das ist also ein super typ
und seit ich das mache geht es mein
tomaten wirklich viel viel besser dann
kommen wir zu drei unterschiedlichen
arten der düngung die man durchführen
kann bei den tomaten das ist einmal die
grunddüngung von der ich ja auch gerade
gesprochen habe die düngung die man den
tomaten bei der pflanzung mit ins
pflanzloch gibt oder wie man vor der
pflanzung in den boden ein arbeitet da
gebe ich ja gerne hornspäne magnesium
sulfat und uhr gesteinsmehl in gleichen
teilen mit ins pflanzloch da mische ich
mir immer dann diese geheime düngern
mixtur zusammen wenn euch das
interessiert schaut gerne noch mal das
video zum tomatenpflanzen an da zeige
ich euch das ganz genau das ist die
grunddüngung die habt ihr aber
wahrscheinlich schon gemacht denn jetzt
war die tomaten ja in der regel schon in
der erde
und jetzt wird eine andere form der
dämmung interessant gerade weil wir ja
in das pflanzloch hornspäne gegeben
haben die sich erstmal umsetzen müssen
im boden bevor sie den pflanzen
überhaupt zur verfügung stehen hornspäne
sind zwar ein super tomaten dinger aber
die haben einen nachteil es dauert
ungefähr sechs wochen bis die überhaupt
anfangen pflanzen verfügbar zu werden
weil die pflanzen wie hornspäne nicht
sofort auf essen können sondern wir
müssen erst durch mikroorganismen
umgewandelt werden in pflanzen
verfügbare nährstoffe und das dauert
seine zeit so dass die pflanzen wenn du
sie mit dieser kündigung gedüngt hast
noch nicht sofort mit den nährstoffen
versorgt sind die sie eigentlich
brauchen deswegen ist es wichtig dass
wir die tomaten während der saison immer
wieder mit regelmäßigen düngergaben
unterstützen und ihnen noch schneller
verfügbaren dünger in form einer flüssig
düngung über das gießwasser zur
verfügung stellen das ist dann also die
regelmäßige düngung das kannst du so
ungefähr alle vier wochen machen je
nachdem wie die tomaten aussehen wenn
sie denen das schon an wenn sie
stickstoff mangel haben das zeige ich
euch gleich noch ich habe hier so ein
paar tomaten die nicht ganz so gut
aussehen glücklicherweise für dieses
video so dass ich euch das gleich
demonstrieren kann
aber es ist eben ganz wichtig dass man
dann regelmäßig den sommer über direkt
nach dem pflanzen kann man da an
fangen noch diese flüssigdünger mischung
mitte dazu gibt dafür könnt ihr entweder
einen fertigen tomaten dünger neben
bitte ein bio dünger das ist wirklich
ganz wichtig ist also mir zumindest das
sehr wichtig ist und man darauf achtet
dass das kein chemischer dünger ist da
kann ich euch gerne mal einen dünger mit
dem ich gute erfahrungen gemacht habe
unten in der video beschreibung
verlinken den ich euch gerne empfehlen
kann ich kann euch gerne alle sachen die
ich hier erwähne einfach als link noch
in die video beschreibung packen so dass
ihr da schauen kind was ich verwende
anderer toller dünger den mann sogar
selber machen kann ist trainer sie auch
da kann ich euch auch gerne mal eine
anleitung für ihn wenn euch das
interessiert wie man brennessel
herstellt alle die in meinem
gemüsegarten staaten kurs mit dabei sind
wissen das natürlich also schaut dann
noch mal rein
da habt ihr die anleitung wie das
funktioniert ja damit könnt ihr eure
tomaten also sehr gut regelmäßig dingen
wie gesagt alle drei bis vier wochen
ich würde aber nicht unbedingt jedes mal
bei einer suche verwenden sondern ab und
zu auch einen biologischen tomaten
dünger oder wie nasse verwenden wie nass
ist auch ein super toller tomaten dünger
das wird aus zuckerrohr hergestellt ist
auch ein biologischer dünger den ich
super gerne an meinen tomaten verwendet
weil das wirklich einen richtigen
stickstoff schub gibt also es gibt
wenige biologische dünger die so stark
dingen wie nasse das grenzt schon an die
wirkung von mineralischen düngern es
wirklich ein krasses zeit passt auf eure
hände auf wenn ihr das verwendet ich
habe eben meine tomaten damit gedenkt
und dort sofort einen ganzen bringen
hier
da kriegt man diese braune flecken und
das klebt dann alles freuen aber ich
liebe die nasa das ist wirklich ein
cooles zeug das verlinkt ich euch auch
in der video beschreiben also entweder
brennessel auch alle drei bis vier
wochen geben oder einen biologischen
tomaten dinger der genau auf die
bedürfnisse der tomaten abgestimmt ist
oder wie nasse auch ein ganz cooles zeug
und da am besten wenn es euch möglich
ist immer ein bisschen abwechseln
weil brennessel auch jetzt nicht
unbedingt alle nährstoffe in der menge
enthält die tomaten brauchen so dass es
ganz gut ist eine der beiden anderen
dünger zwischendurch auch noch mal zu
verwenden und die dritte form der
düngung ist die notfallübung da könnt
ihr wenn irgendetwas ungewöhnliches mit
eurem tomaten passiert wenn irgendwelche
komischen blätter bekommen flecken
bekommen dann könnt ihr in einer liste
die ich euch gerne hier unter dem video
verlinkt mal nachschauen was das denn
sein könnte
das sind ja oft schädlinge krankheiten
oder nährstoffmangel und dann könnt ihr
gucken haben eure tomaten vielleicht ein
kalziummangel dann dementsprechend
gezielt diesen stoff der euren tomaten
fehlt nachdenken also ich hab euch deine
liste unten verlinkt die ist auf meinem
blog könnt ihr schauen nach den
symptomen ist uns immer gegliedert was
euren tomaten fehlt ich habe da ganz
viele tomaten probleme aufgelistet so
dass da hoffentlich dass dabei ist was
für euch gerade schief läuft erkennt ihr
gerne rein schauen wenn irgendetwas
ungewöhnliches an euren tomaten auftritt
ja wie hat sich denn bemerkbar und man
jetzt zu viel denkt das kann natürlich
auch sein erst mal wenn ihr euch
überlegt wie viel soll ich den dünnen
schaut mal auf die packung drauf des
düngers den hier verwendet ich kann euch
da jetzt keine allgemeingültigen rezepte
an die hand geben weil ich ja nicht weiß
wie euer diener dosiert ist aber das
steht normalerweise immer mit drauf
niemanden an den tomaten anwendet dann
wie gesagt einfach mit ins gießwasser
geben und die tomaten damit düngen und
wenn ihr merkt dass eure tomaten ganz
ganz dunkelgrüne fast schon schwarze
blätter bekommen dann ist das ein
zeichen dafür dass ihr es vielleicht ein
bisschen zu gut gemeint habt und die
pflanzen überdüngt ab jetzt sprechen wir
noch mal wie man dann erkennt ob sie
vielleicht unter dutt sind also ob eure
tomaten vielleicht ein bisschen hungrig
sind dafür gehen wir mal dahin war kommt
mit
da gibt es ein ganz gutes
erkennungszeichen zumindest was den
stickstoff mangel an geht was ja der
häufigste mangel ist weil das der
wichtigste pflanzennährstoff für euro
tomaten ist und das sind gelbe blätter
und ich habe sie über meinen freiland
tomaten die ein bisschen zu lange in
ihren töpfen ausharren mussten das
perfekte beispiel da sind nämlich jetzt
schon die unteren blätter gelb gefärbt
und
darin seht ihr dass die pflanzen
stickstoff brauchen die fangen immer in
den unteren brettern an den stickstoff
zu entziehen um ihn dann in die oberen
neueren blätter eins zu pumpen so machen
die pflanzen dass die unteren blätter
sind die am wenigsten wichtigen blätter
deswegen müssen die als erstes dran
glauben und da erkennt ihr dann relativ
bald schon ob euren pflanzendünger fehlt
in dem fall hier mit meinen freiland
tomaten die jetzt wirklich schon sehr
gelbe unteren blätter haben teilweise
sind auch die mittleren blätter schon
relativ geld würde ich jetzt als erstes
eine grimasse anrühren also dass die wie
nasse mit in das gießwasser geben
da müsst ihr einfach mal auf die packung
schauen wieder diese dosierung ist je
nachdem was für ein produkt ihr euch da
an schafft weil die sagen ganz ganz
deutlich dass sie hunger haben und dass
jetzt dringend dünger brauchen die es
ist auch nicht so schlimm wenn es mal
vorkommt also da müsst ihr euch keine
sorgen machen wenn die pflanzen mal
einen mangel anzeigen
einfach schnell reagieren schnell
nachdenken und dann erholen die sich
wieder und wachsen fröhlich und munter
weiter wenn ihr noch mehr fragen habt
rund um die tomate irgendwelche probleme
die euch belasten irgendwelche fragen
auch um die selbstversorgung in den
gemüsegarten dann schreibt mir das gerne
in die kommentare ich sammle gerade
ideen für neue videos da bin ich auf
jeden fall sehr gespannt was ihr euch so
wünscht ich will ja die videos machen
die euch am besten weiter helfen also
helft mir bitte mit ideen ich freue mich
auf jeden fall auf euch übrigens falls
ihr das noch nicht wussten
ich bin immer samstags zwischen 10 und
11 sie auf youtube online und
beantwortet ihre fragen unten in den
kommentaren das muss auch gar nicht um
das thema gehen worum es in dem video
geht dann kommt gerne da dazu das ist
meine ganz nette plauderstunde da freue
ich mich immer schon jede woche drauf
damit euch ein bisschen direkten
austausch zu haben ich versuche
natürlich auch unter der woche immer mal
kommentare zu beantworten aber wir haben
ja jetzt schon hier 30 tausend
abonnenten was übrigens richtig cool ist
und da schaffe ich es nicht alle fragen
zu beantworten aber wenn euch irgendwas
auf der seele brennt werden welche ganz
dringenden fragen habt dann kommt immer
samstags mit dazu oder wenn ihr einfach
nur ein paar nette worte mit mir
wechseln wollte oder mit den anderen
zuschauen ist unglaublich das ist eine
blattlaus oder die mir da gerade über
das gesicht krabbelt ich mache ich bei
ihm ein video über blattläuse ja wenn
interessiert schreibt es in die
kommentare
wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat und
wenn euch das weitergeholfen hat dann
gebt ihm gerne einen daumen nach oben da
freue ich mich wirklich ungemein drüber
das ist auch etwas das wusst ich bevor
ich mit youtube angefangen habe
überhaupt nicht dass das einen
youtube-kanal wirklich so weiterhilft
wenn man da diese bäumchen nach oben
bekommt also da bin ich immer sehr
dankbar dafür danke für alle die es
immer schon machen
ich werde jetzt von den blattläusen
befreien und sagen tschüss bis nächste
woche
und die erfahrung die falsch nochmal
kommt irgendwann ganz autokolonne vorbei
die tomaten schönen nicht wachsen können
die dritte form der dünnen ist so
genannte notice nicht so wenn man ich
hab die so genannt
[Musik]
marien heißt es zusammen